how suspicious should i be when i'm
traveling in ukraine or different parts
of the world when when an attractive
female walks up to me and shows any kind
of attention
is that is that like this kind of james
bond spy movie stuff or is that kind of
stuff used by
intelligence agencies i don't think it's
used it's absolutely used it's called
sexbionage
it's that's the term that we jokingly
call it is espionage
but yeah the the art of attraction
appeal
um
the manifestation of feelings through
sexual manipulation
all of that is a super powerful tool uh
the chinese use it extremely well the
russians use it extremely well
in the united states we actively train
our officers not to use it
because in the end it leads to
complications in how you professionally
run a case so we train our officers not
to use it however
you can't control what other people
think so if you're an attractive male or
an attractive female officer and you're
hap you're trying to talk to a
you know an older general who just
happens to be gay or happens to be
straight and is attracted to you of
course they're going to be that much
more willing to talk to an american who
is also attractive
so it's hard to walk that back in all
definitions so it could be
all elements of charisma
that's
so
you know
attractiveness in the dynamic sense of
the word so it's visual attractiveness
but the the smile the humor the wit the
the flirting all that kind of stuff that
could be used
to uh
correct to the art of conversation
there's also elements of sexuality that
people
underestimate right so physical
sexuality physical attraction is the
most obvious one it's the one that
everybody talks about and thinks about
but then there's also sapiosexuality
which is being sexually attracted to
uh to thoughts to intelligence and then
you've got all the various varieties of
of
personal preferences some people like
people of a certain color skin or they
like big noses they like small noses
they like big butts they like small
butts they like tall guys they like bald
guys whatever it might be
you can't ever predict
what someone's preferences sexual uh
arousal preferences are going to be
so then you end up walking into a
situation where then you discover
you know and just imagine imagine being
being an unattractive overweight married
guy
and you're walking into uh an asset or a
target meeting with like a middle-aged
female who is also not very attractive
and also married but then it turns out
that that person is a sapiosexual and
gets extremely turned on by intelligent
conversation that's exactly what you're
there to do your exact your mission is
to have
intelligent conversation with this
person to find out if they have access
to secrets and by virtue of you carrying
out your mission they become extremely
aroused and attracted to you that is a
very complicated situation it's hard to
know to trust like how do you know your
wife or how does your wife know that
you're not a double agent from russia
i there's a a large element of
uh of experience and time that goes into
that she's also trained
uh and i
i think my wife and i also think my wife
and i also have the benefit
of
being recruited
uh young and together where
so over time you can start to figure out
things that are very difficult to
uh do so when you form the baseline you
start to understand the person's very it
becomes very difficult to lie the most
difficult thing in the world is
consistency it's the most difficult
thing in the world some people say that
discipline or self-discipline what
they're really talking about is
consistency when you have someone who
performs consistently over long periods
of time under various levels of stress
you have high high confidence that that
is the person that you can trust you can
trust again
you can trust them to
behave within a certain pattern
you can trust an [ __ ] to be an
[ __ ]
without trusting the [ __ ] to take
care of your kids right so i don't ever
want to mix up the idea of personal
trust
versus trusting the outcome you can
always trust a person to operate within
their pattern of behavior it just takes
time for you to get a consistent uh to
get consistent feedback as to what that
baseline is for them to to form a good
model
predictive model of what their behavior
is going to be like right and you know
what's fascinating is i think
the challenge is building that model
quickly
so technology is one of those tools that
will be able in the future to very
quickly create
a model of behavior because technology
can pull in multiple data points
in a very short period of time that the
human brain simply can't pull in at the
same period at the same space at the
same speed well that's actually what i
did my phd on that's what i did at
google is forming a good representation
unique representation across the entire
world based on the behavior of the
person
the the specific task there is so that
you
don't have to type in the password the
idea was to replace the password uh but
it also allows you to actually study
human behavior and to think all right
what is the unique representation of a
person
how
because we have very specific patterns
and a lot of humans are very similar in
those patterns what are the unique
identifiers within those patterns of
behavior
and that's i think that's from a
psychology perspective a super
fascinating question
and from a machine learning perspective
it's something that you can as the
systems get better and better and better
and as we get more and more
digital data about each individual you
start to get
you start to be able to do that kind of
thing effectively and it's i mean when i
think of the fact that you could create
a dossier on somebody in a matter of 24
or 48 hours if you could wire
them for two days
right internet of things style you put
it in their underwear or whatever right
some some chip that just reads
everything
how heavy are they walking how much time
do they sleep how many times they open
the refrigerator when they log into
their computer how do they do it like
which hand do they use when they log in
yeah what what's their most common swipe
what's their most visited website you
could collect an enormous amount
of normative data in a short period of
time where otherwise we're stuck
the way that we do it now
once or twice a week we go out for a
coffee for two hours
and two hours at a time over the course
of six eight weeks twelve weeks you're
coming up with a fifty percent
assessment on how you think this person
is going to behave
just that time savings is immense
you